they say wait hold on let me see so you
walk to the window coolest yeah
also dress shoes we slid over there a
little bit all those suckers about the
pain
oh boy strong with junior
they were liberal from get out renewing
our faith a TSA agents
first of all from Chicago and you know
Chicago's known for a lot of things you
know hot dogs pizza the Cubs won the
World Series and violence a lot of
violence and my father is one of
those dudes who's from an old era like
he wasn't a black panther but he was
like in a gang that I guess didn't
really exist for I don't know I don't
necessarily believe him a that he
was in the real game but he isn't when I
was early at Yankee like babe wrestlers
for the community and what people cross
the street that type of the true
story right so we grew up I lived in a
bad neighborhood growing up you know in
most neighborhoods you just thought you
know a neighborhood bad when people sit
on anybody car car do you know you got a
humbly accident excuse me I know y'all
just having a good time checking on my
cop but I need to go to work this evenin
as you're soaking so I'm getting off the
bus one day and I'm walking down the
street and I see a bunch of dudes on the
car my old fuddy on my father's car and
I go upstairs I'm going back and forth
cause he still think he could take these
young people I don't know why
not
I got a 70s dad I don't know if anybody
had a 70s father growing up like what a
cool bumper right is he said my daddy
used to walk just like this this is
eight-ten be talking like he had to PA
man which one of you suck is taking out
the garbage at any time so for some
reason he's still piggy toughest so
get in the house I'm like I I'm gonna
tell them they on his car but I hope you
don't do no extra
so money dad look now before I tell you
this tell me you gonna chill out go
through what to do okay never mind
all right look it's a bunch of dude
sitting in your car right so they say
what see hold on let me see so you walk
to the window coolest yeah also
dress shoes we slid over there a little
bit
[Applause]
I don't suck is about to pay I'm like
wait a minute so something look man I
gotta tell you that these are gangster
disciples okay
they had a documentary on him a few
weeks ago but a biography channel I
don't think you're gonna do this
they were murder you say look he's gotta
know the site boo okay I was a dragon
what the is a dragon well you know
Joe gang gotta be mean that that's
not even real you know I was so
dragged in I said look hey
let's use a dragon uh-huh look man we
was a gang and a ban wait I don't give a
if y'all go through these young
dudes would murder you out there so let
me tell you something okay you don't
believe me do you I'll say I think I
don't believe you're a dragon I just I
mean I just don't believe in dragons
okay I gotta prove it okay so my mom was
in the kitchen he's a baby could you get
my dragon jacket right my mama smoked
cigarettes look which one blue Jade of
the leather right she get this dragon
Jack it was not even a jacket right it's
the best it's really a dragon vest but
he called it a jacket on the way the
sleeves was cut off the jacket it was
shingling at the shoulders
he had a big colorful dragon on that go
kind of faded cuz he watched a couple
times and he had his real name he even
have a gang name say Milton on the front
I didn't need one
I was Milton on the bongos okay whatever
so you put all this dragon check it
right now he took his whole shirt off
cuz I guess they do wear shirts with the
best at that time so he took his up
now he just all chest hair Shawn he had
a chain in the chest it was like a
little cross I could tell it was a cross
oh I don't know what it was but the
others the chest it was all around a
little charm yeah he started getting
ready right which is weirdest I've never
seen nobody get ready for a fight look
at the Oh spike so he got some always
fights put it on for a fight I've never
seen somebody put on cologne before a
fight
so you got this little ass baby
fat vest that's what it was so these
little dudes look at him come outside he
come outside
kula looking at a man who the
is this old ass do with this warriors
off you know he let me kiss someone tell
you I am right now my name is Milton
Milton Howry and I counted like you said
known as mine I pay the payments right
like man look old man we don't wanna
beat your ass and you all by
yourself all by myself
Jimmy on his way now what I forgot to
tell you out that he called Jimmy who's
the only other living dragon left a
[Applause]
Jimmy don't no one's going Jimmy to
graduate from the gangs he's just a
businessman to drop a van with a blue
too far that's it
so Jimmy pull up with this van right you
can tell the oldest man could have had
curtains on and he pull up pull up yeah
Billy ocean plan D full of like he put
here claim when he pull up then walk to
the car like oh god what's going on
Jimmy look here okay we about to have a
rumble Jimmy oh like you ever see
somebody so old they gotta take up their
glasses just to hear you
so my daddy's Jim you look at Jimmy I'm
trying to team what's going on
look what wait hold on wait damn fight I
thought it's paid to think oh he's
playing cars today
you owe your all I'm done with the
Dragons he drove off I mean it ain't no
punch I see like they beat the up
my daddy right they beat him up and
I was like a look you ain't gonna help
with you just you saw my father best on
the street and cars driving over the
house she it to me like look you
look at your daddy this and we get back
upstairs like a wash and that's what
happened yeah that's it